hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over
the danish bird trap now this derives
from the danish gambit one of my
favorite chess openings with e4
e5 and then after d4 in the pawn takes
white says we're not done giving up
material let's go ahead and play pawn
to c3 hey black if you want to keep
gobbling up material that's fine with me
and black many times will just continue
to gobble on material pawn takes here on
c3
bishop to c4 black says yeah let's just
keep gobbling out material here on
b2 then after the bishop takes you can
see white has
taken one pawn black has taken three
pawn so black is up two pawns in
material but white does have
a very strong attack already you can see
the queen
is completely open to attack both the
bishops are eyeing down
on the king side of the board for a very
strong attack
and from black's standpoint none of the
material left on the board
has moved at all just that one single
pawn
started here on e7 did all the movement
so far from black so yes black is up but
it is very difficult to
play in this position from black now
many times if they're not familiar with
how to do this because there's
lots of ways that black can continue
here as they may try to start an
attack and one of the most common ways
in chess to
look for an attack is as soon as a
bishop moves especially from white stand
points
to always look at the g2 pawn and the b2
pawn you can see this g2 pawn
once this light square bishop moves away
it is undefended since it's only
protected by the bishop early on so
queen to g5 definitely makes some sense
get the queen the most powerful piece
on the board uh get involved into the
game attack this pawn here on g2 black
may be thinking hey i'm already up two
pawns of material
as long as i don't screw this up i
should have a pretty easy game here so
let's go ahead and get my most important
piece involved into the game
attacking this pawn now white really
should not be thinking about
losing this pawn right here instead
should only be thinking about
getting more material involved into the
game that's the whole point of
the danish gambit is to get as much
material involved into the game so that
should include knight two f
three
and this is really where the trap comes
from now this was played many years ago
by henry bird he was playing against
lasker
and so we'll go over his specific
variation
in this trap but i'm going to go over
lots of different things that you could
encounter
if they fall for it completely and play
incorrectly
we'll show you that as well as if they
don't completely mess it up how you can
still capitalize and have a
very good game so if they play queen to
g5 many times they're looking to capture
this pawn here on
g2 now that would be a mistake here but
it's tough to see right away
how that is a mistake but after queen
takes on g2
then white's gonna play rook to g1 now
this queen you can see
doesn't have a lot of options can't take
the rook here
on g1 or the pawn here on h2 both of
those are protected by this knight here
on
f3 can't take the knight it's protected
by the queen here on g1
can't move along this g file it is being
attacked by this rook here so the only
safe square
is queen to h3 now if if black's really
looking at this and says
i don't just want to retreat right away
let's go ahead and get an
in-between move and attack my opponent
with the only other piece that i can get
involved into the action right now
and that is the bishop so bishop down to
b4
check but luckily for whites
they can just play king 2 e2 now they
don't want to play something like knight
2
c3 because that does stop the attack
from this dark square bishop here on b2
eyeing down this long dark square
diagonal but
it doesn't really matter if the king
comes here to e2 yes
you have lost the right to castle but
that doesn't matter you're not really
going to be castling on the king side
because the rook's already moved and you
don't want to castle on the queen side
because
you've already given up all the pawns in
front of that so it doesn't really
matter too much
as far as where your king is at it all
matters where your pieces are on the
board for you to attack your opponent
now
from black standpoint how do they
continue they don't have any other
attacks
to check the king and so now it comes
down to okay now they
have to play queen two h3 or they're
going to lose
their queen and from here white can
start
the attack with the first move being
bishop takes here on f7 i'll go through
all the iterations of
where the black king could go but let's
start with just the king takes here on
f7
because that's the most obvious knight
to g5 for king the king this is
check and then after the king moves then
the queen is going to fall here on
h3 if we come back going clockwise
instead of the king taking here on f7 if
king two e7
then rook takes here on g7 this
long dark square diagonal still being
attacked by the bishop here on b2
and really this is threatening the move
bishop to
e6 and the king can't just take here on
e6 because you still have that knight to
g5 that would again fork the king here
on e6 and capture this queen so if you
start to look at
okay the bishop comes here to e6 that's
a discovered attack with the rook
that's really going to be attacking this
queen once the bishop moves and so the
the queen is almost
under attack by the move with rook takes
here on a g7 so how does the queen
really
get out of this he can't move along this
light square diagonal
can't come here to g4 just fall to the
rook
can't come here to f5 fall to the pawn
can't come here to e6
fall to the the bishop here can't come
to h4
and you can see that just queen to h5
has the it's just gonna lose immediately
to the bishop here on f7 so the only
option for black to hold on to the queen
is to play
queen to h6 but then
white can take here on g8
after the queen takes it looks pretty
bad this is check right here so
if the queen does not take maybe king to
d8 well then all of a sudden just rook
down here to g3
and black has just nothing else left to
do here the root can't take because it's
just going to fall
to this rook taking it on g8 but then if
you say well
if it doesn't take then it's just going
to fall on the next move with bishop
takes here on h8
there's no strong attack that black has
all this material here on the queen side
of the board can't move anywhere
so that just looks pretty awkward but if
they do take let's say bishop takes on
g8
if the queen takes here on a g7 then the
queen is just going to fall so
none of those options are going to go
well for black so after the queen 2h6
which is really the only good move
uh that just doesn't lose the queen
automatically
black is still going to end up losing
so if we come back instead of king 2 e7
which you already know is going to lose
uh maybe instead they play king 2 d8
and this is when bird actually played
this which
the move we're going over is the danish
bird trap
uh he actually played the move bishop
takes here on
g7 so both the bishops up here just
cutting off
every single square that black could
really go to attacking
this rook right here on h8 and then
lasker played the move
knight to e7 just saying okay yeah i'm
gonna lose
this rook here uh there's nothing i can
do about that let's go and get my knight
involved
into the game uh but this loses because
knight
two g5 attacking the queen there's no
real good squares for the queen to go to
uh the queen came here to h4 and then
there is a smothered mate here with
knight to e6 uh being smothered by the
pawn and the pawn is being pinned down
by the queen here
on d1 so it can't really move anywhere
and it can't come here to e8 because it
is
being attacked by this bishop here on f7
so that is the
checkmate in that particular game that's
where we get the name from the danish
bird trap but doesn't have to
play the knight to e7 there's just
no other good squares for black to
really go to
because the rook's gonna fall here on h8
uh then you can
get your queen involved into the game
you can attack the queen here on h3
just lots of different options so we've
looked at uh
some of the moves and the last move from
black standpoint is they could play king
2 f 8.
same situation as if they played king 2
d8
this is just more awkward for black
because bishop takes here on
g7 check and the bishop here on g7
is protected by the rook now remember
anytime they take that bishop here on
f7 just going to fork them knight to g5
check and then take their queen here on
h3 so uh this just gets even worse
for black and so from here it doesn't
really matter where they go we're going
to capture this material here on h8
unless they want to give up their queen
that is a another option so that's what
happens if they completely fall for the
trap if we come back
and say okay what if what if after this
rook to g1
they don't play bishop to b4
because we already looked at okay the
bishop here on f8
that just leaves open
if that bishop moves then the the pawn
here on g7
falls pretty easily so what if the
bishop doesn't move because the king
coming here to e2 is not a significant
weakness for white
so black in this case is gonna
automatically just bring the queen to h3
recognize their mistake not get into any
more trouble with bishop here to b4
but in this spot it's still pretty bad
for black so bishop takes here on
f7 we know they can't take
so that's definitely not going to work
king 2 d8 probably their best option
here
but now we can play rook takes here on
g7 now as soon as this rook moves
it's going to be a open long
dark square diagonal to take this rook
here on h8 so we're normally going to
see the bishop take
and then the bishop take here on g7
attacking the rook
and this is where there's not a lot of
great options here you could
play something like d6 okay well
just trying to open up the door for the
light square bishop to get involved
but then the bishop just takes here on
h8 that doesn't feel really good
they could always get their queen so
maybe queen to
g4 and then after we take here on h8
which they cannot stop
then they take here on e4
check but then queen to e2
attacking the queen says yeah if you
want to trade off that's fine we're just
up so much material and also if they
move their queen
they have to be cautious because queen
to e8
would be checkmate if they move their
queen to the wrong spot so
in many cases they almost have to take
here but after the king takes
you can see they're they're in a pretty
tough spot they need to move their
knight they don't want to move it to f6
because that would just fall to the
bishop here
on h8 so they're looking at knight to e7
and then knight to
c3 but if you look at the material white
is up a minor piece
and a rook that's not going to be good
they have a pass pawn here on the f-file
there's no way black should even be in
this game
and white should have a pretty easy end
game from here so that is the danish
bird trap
with the few variations that you could
potentially see if they don't fall for
it completely
either way white's definitely going to
have a good game so if your opponent
ever plays
queen 2 g5 in the danish gambit you
should uh your eyes should light up
and just hope that after you played
knight to f3
that they come down and take here and
take the bait for the trap here on
g2 hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
thanks for all the support of the
channel if you have any suggestions for
future videos
please let me know in the comments below
or you can always email me as well at
the test website at
gmail.com but thanks so much and i'll
see you guys in
the next video
you